I think that fear and isolation are
tools of the enemy and I think right now
in this time of physical isolation or if
you have to destocialize find a way to
love somebody and hug them in a way that
you can because we need our hearts and
our heads to be cared for as well
Elizabeth Hasselbeck returned to the
view on Wednesday and Rosie O'Donnell
ain't having it I asked you if you
believed what the Republican pundits
were saying yes you said nothing and
that's no no no no nothing do not do
will not call me a card of course that
was the lady's Infamous fight from 2007
when they were both co-hosts on the show
and though it's been 13 years it seems
there's no love lost at least on Rosie's
side and here's why on Wednesday
Elizabeth shared her thoughts on the
coronavirus epidemic I think that
there's there can be a fine line between
what is precaution right what is taking
precaution what is panic and so I think
um I think a lot of it has to be decided
yes we're going to take precautions
we're going to
um Purell pray that God's got us in our
tomorrows right we pray that this
coronavirus is extinguished that it that
it stops in its tracks and I love the
fact that we can identify that this is
precautionary she made her position
clear she's not panicking which Drew
criticism from Joy Behar Sunny Hostin
and Rosie she tweeted oh dear God not
again enough with her it's your own
thoughts right but every time I defend
them Elizabeth it's poor little
Elizabeth that I'm picking on you know
what little Elizabeth is not poor little
Elizabeth that's right that's why I'm
not gonna fight with you anymore the
television personalities have a
complicated history not only did they
exchange words on air in 2007 Elizabeth
had this to say in 2014 about Rosie's
brief return to the daytime show
taught not securing the Border here in
comes to The View
s of our military
and in the face of her own network and
really in the face of a person who stood
by here and had civilized debates
um for the time that she was there and
the feud ignited last year after Rosie
revealed in the book ladies who punch
that she had a little crush on Elizabeth
while they were co-hosting the view
together Elizabeth reacted during an
appearance on Fox and Friends it was
disturbing to read those things and it
was offensive to me but I forgive her I
totally forgive you Rosie and I think
that I really hope that we can be at
peace as for Rosie she responded during
an Instagram live it's crazy I don't
know she was so afraid of the concept of
a lesbian having a crush on her that she
had to go directly to Jesus do not pass
go do not collect two hundred dollars
[Music]